so this is a working DeLorean with the
real flux it is working and flexing at
the moment so yeah it's an exact replica
of the screen-used movie car that you
see in this one is back in the Back to
the Future 2 movie so you've got the mr.
fusion on the back though it's not a
real time machine but it is a real
DeLorean nothing about the hitter that's
1980s British supercar that's right it
is it's an original 1981 DeLorean made
in the maroon Northern Ireland they made
around about 9,000 or so originally and
it came probably most famous in the end
for being in the Back to the Future
movies and this is what you see in the
movie screen car was designed by a guy
called Kevin Pike and his team in
America and they basically picked up
loads of capacitors and parts off of
aircrafts and various bits I went into a
depo basically and started picking bits
off the show they looked cool that's the
out so what have we got in here all
these bits and bobs we've got the time
turkic control switch which turns on the
time tickets here which is probably one
of the most iconic parts of the car
where you punch in your destination time
that is then followed by the flux
capacitor
which is what makes time travel possible
that is activated when the speedometer
reaches 88 miles an hour which of course
would be illegal on UK it word yeah so
we can change the kilometers get through
it that way and yeah that then activates
all the time circuits the dates change
and work and move as they did in the
movies it looks fantastic obviously
board like to actually drive there's
nothing on the roads it gets as much as
attention as the Dorian and but it
doesn't quite match up to a modern car
but that's part of their charm
they are passed away no power steering
no is it's quite a heavy car but it
looks great
and it cruises nicely and yeah you've
got a treat like a classic car really